absolutely crazy news broke yesterday
former white house chief strategist to
donald trump steve
bannon was arrested and indicted on
multiple charges for defrauding
thousands of donors
through those crazy bill uh we build the
wall
initiatives that he was a part of and it
was
bannon and three other people indicted
in a federal investigation in the
southern district of new york
what prosecutors say went down is that
bannon and three others defrauded donors
by raising more than 25 million bucks to
build a wall along the southern border
of the united states
and that a bunch of the money was used
for personal gain
there there are so many stories here
remember when this was happening
when there was this idea that hey if
trump can't get the money from the libs
or the dems then we'll just raise the
money privately
turns out that steve bannon was involved
in one of those schemes
at the time i said who's stupid enough
to donate to this
to think that this is a project that
individuals can actually do
and if they did donate to it is it so
stupid that they deserve
what's coming to them which is to lose
their money but clearly this is a scam
and we were right
but the scam is one that steve bannon
is involved in to the tune of 25 million
dollars
the other people indicted inclu include
that guy brian
colfage who's the guy we reported on
when this money was actually being
raised
and of course now the distancing with
steve bannon by some will start
trump i'm sure will say this is very
unfair
these were people looking to do
something that the dems didn't want to
do they were doing a good thing raising
money for the wall of course that's not
what
what's at issue what's that issue uh is
that uh it is was allegedly a
money laundering wire fraud scheme and
there there was this funny picture over
the weekend
of steve bannon being interviewed on fox
news and looking really haggard and a
lot of people were laughing about it and
commenting on it
maybe he knew this was coming and that's
why his appearance was so bizarre and
outrageous and federal prosecutors have
a lot of details here
they say that when donors were donating
to this project they were assured
100 of the money we raised will go to
build the wall
and i could tell that wasn't true many
of you could tell that wasn't true
anybody with any common sense could tell
they're not using
25 million to build the wall people
started writing to brian
colfidge and uh
it started to get weird and then it
turns out
that these guys were profiting from this
profiting from and and again i
sort of said if you donate to this
you're so stupid you deserve to lose
your money
still criminality is alleged here and so
if there are criminals and they can be
proven to be criminals they should be
prosecuted
morally maybe there's a different
argument to be made but
certainly there should be prosecution
and we're talking about
these individuals taking hundreds of
thousands of dollars
from the donations essentially creating
uh
really like their own slush fund in a
sense
and now the pr will start and now we are
going to see this turned into yet
another one of these political witch
hunts as many claim
that the trump investigations have been
and the trump impeachment
have been but don't be confused if it
smells like a duck
and it walks like a duck and it sounds
like a duck it's often a duck
uh or someone pretending to be a duck
and in this case
uh this was all of the above and more
to sort of uh go to the end of the
analogies and metaphors but
is anybody if anybody is truly surprised
by this i would be shocked
but that's the latest steve bannon
indicted
are we going to hear bannon i don't
remember bannon was he like an intern
maybe for a brief period in 2015
no this guy was on the national security
council at one point or at least he sat
in the meetings
this is serious and they're going to
pretend it's not but this is absolutely
outrageous
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars just for
using their free service at
privacy.com pacman privacy is a service
i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want i especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman